we had huge news yesterday which is that
joe biden will get an opportunity to
select the first of we don't know how
many supreme court justices during his
presidency we learned yesterday that
if democrats don't screw it up and
unfortunately i already will have an
example for you today
of a democrat who seems to not
understand the risks here and that this
could end up getting getting screwed up
um 83 year old supreme court justice
stephen breyer plans to retire and as a
result joe biden will get to replace
a liberal justice with a liberal justice
and that is an important factor here in
that this will not change the balance of
the court
but it will ensure that breyer's seat
will stay with
the left the liberals whatever term you
want to apply
um for some period of time that will be
dependent on the age of the person
selected to replace breyer so nbc news
reporting justice stephen breyer to
retire from the court paving the way for
a biden appointment the liberal
justice's decision to step down after
more than 27 years on the court
allows biden to appoint a successor who
could serve for decades biden and breyer
is scheduled to appear together at the
white house today as the supreme court
will announce his retirement that may
have happened by the time you listen to
today's show brian is one of three
briar rather is one of the three
remaining liberal justices his decision
to retire after more than 27 years on
the court allows biden to appoint a
successor who could serve for decades in
the short term maintaining the current
6-3 split between conservative and
liberal justices this is a really
important aspect of this which we're
going to talk about we're replacing a
liberal with a liberal
it doesn't shift the court trump's big
thing
was putting in amy coney barrett to
replace ruth bader ginsburg replacing
a liberal
with a pretty serious conservative now
joe biden previously said he would
appoint a black woman to the supreme
court who would be the first black woman
ever on the supreme court
um it does appear as though that is
still the plan
there has been a short list of potential
nominees released and one of the
uh primary names that really i mean
listen we don't yet know but the person
being mentioned as the front runner
is judge kitanji brown jackson who was
appointed last year to the u.s court of
appeals in washington d.c and so you can
take a look at that short list that is
out there
but d.c circuit judge katanji brown
jackson at the top of the list
california supreme court justice leandra
krueger is believed to be on the list
south carolina u.s district court judge
michelle child on the list and others uh
white house press secretary jen saki
yesterday asked about joe biden's
commitment to putting a black woman on
the court and she had the following to
say go ahead thanks jen two subjects so
let's say hypothetically
a supreme court justice
was to retire and announce it on his or
her own terms
does president biden plan to honor his
pledge to nominate a black woman to the
court well i've commented on this
previously the president has uh stated
and reiterated his commitment to
nominating a black woman to the supreme
court and certainly uh stands by that
for today again i'm just not going to
be able to say anything about uh any
specifics until of course uh justice
breyer makes any uh announcement should
he decide to make an announcement okay
so immediately there is
argument disagreement controversy over
this
there are some on the right who are
saying
this is racism this is racism you are
preemptively saying
i will not consider white people for the
position therefore it's racist to say
we're going to appoint a black woman to
the supreme court
now i think that's a terribly bad faith
argument and i i must give the following
reminder if not disclaimer to the people
who may not be familiar with my view on
identity politics
i am not an identity politics fan
i am against the use of identity as a
cudgel or to silence
or to
elevate
when it comes to
the world
and that being said i recognize that
one's identity can be an interesting and
relevant factor
in
the exploration
of
topics
of all sorts economic social cultural
whatever the case may be
and so for me
these ideas of i will nominate a black
woman they're not super interesting to
me it doesn't i don't like biden more
because he says i will put a black woman
on the court but
i'm now not so deluded as to think
that this would be the same
as saying i will only put a white person
on the court we have a history in the
united states where we had a supreme
court for the longest period made up
exclusively of white men
and a history of enslaving black people
in the united states so
while i am not an identity politics guy
i recognize
that it would be a relevant milestone
for the country
to say hey we've had for hundreds of
years we've had all these different
types of people in the country
and yet we've never had a black woman on
the court now i also would say this is
not only restricted to black women uh
what about native americans what what
about asians
the the point here is we can
simultaneously
be against the toxic destructive
counterproductive identity politics that
i've been criticizing on the program for
a very long time
and recognize that wait a second we've
never had a black woman on the court oh
it would be a relevant milestone to have
one of course starting from the baseline
that there are countless black women who
would be qualified to be on the court
that's another aspect of this that the
wright is being very bad faith about
which is saying
when you say i'm going to put a black
woman on the court that's that's the
that's a category which i'm going to
seek to fill
you are no longer putting qualified
people there you are choosing identity
over qualifications now if there were no
qualified black women in the country
that might be an argument to be made but
of course there are countless qualified
black women to be on the court and so
the idea that we are sacrificing
qualifications for identity it also is
not the case so i i hope that it's
coming through that we can be
reasonable about this
without falling into these very bad
faith arguments that the right is
seeking to make i think the bigger
concern
is
if and how republicans are going to come
up with a way to block this right i mean
i don't know guys we're only nine months
from a midterm maybe it's too soon to be
confirmed shouldn't the people have a
say or maybe omicron or cancel culture
there must be some reason republic you
know if if briar announces the
retirement today
when the when the retirement is
announced on a thursday
during winter in the northern hemisphere
marjory taylor green gets to pick
instead of biden i'm obviously kidding
but
they may try to figure some way
to try to block this now one other
aspect of this is that on the identity
piece
other presidents have done the same
thing just to be thorough on that
remember when donald trump said this and
none of the republicans went crazy
i will be putting forth the nominee next
week it will be a woman
wow
and the crowd cheered for that it was
okay when trump said it's going to be a
woman or remember this this was this was
uh ronald reagan this is tom brokaw who
remembers this one
ronald reagan today promised to appoint
a woman to the supreme court if he's
elected president whoa
hold isn't that
isn't that identity poli
they're they're total hypocrites they
didn't care when trump did it okay fine
we know that um next thing
i can imagine in all seriousness not
wanting
a seat at the current supreme court
table let me explain what i mean
we have a hyper partisan court right now
we have a court that at 6 30
is making rulings
obviously based on partisan politics and
not
simple sober interpretations of the law
the court is a 6-3 majority right now
for the conservatives and it will remain
a 6-3 majority once breyer is replaced
with whoever joe biden nominates
i'm not sure i would even want to be
part of a court
where my opinion would almost literally
never matter if you had a 5-4
conservative court
with justice roberts who has sided with
liberals in the past
it leaves the possibility that when you
put in a black woman to be part of some
votes that will have an impact and make
a difference there is no chance of that
for as long as this is a 6-3 court now
i'm not literally saying whoever is
nominated should turn it down
but i could understand why a nominee
might think you know it might be better
for my legacy not to be nominated right
now
uh just just a thought that i'm having
and of course if the person is young
enough
they could be appointed they could be
confirmed now
in this kind of futile 6-3 situation and
down the line circumstances change and
they end up being part of some impactful
decisions last thing republicans are
also now pulling this uh
is joe biden going to get rid of the
problematic kamala harris
by putting her on the court here's peter
alexander asking about that there
ginsberg none of that you can share i'm
not going to detail internal planning
from here no okay then let me ask you a
couple other questions is there any
scenario in which the president would
select his vice president kamala harris
for the supreme court
again i'm not going to speak to any
considerations preparations lists
and as we've stated earlier and you
heard the president say it is there's a
long history of supreme court justices
determining when uh they may retire and
then so because gensake didn't rule it
out then peter ducey followed up about
the same thing and then it becomes a
story that uh it's like a runaway train
talked about isn't an initial package
okay thank you good thank you when you
were asked about the vice president
possibly being selected as a supreme
court nominee you said you're not going
to speak to any considerations does that
mean she is being considered
again peter i'm not going to speak to
the reports of a supreme court justice
retirement that hasn't been announced
so um and then fox news was talking
about this and it took on a life of its
own absolute last thing on this
democrats might still screw it up
and
there is a tweet that exemplifies this
from jennifer habercorn quoting senator
dianne feinstein apparently senator
dianne feinstein doesn't see a rush to
confirm a briar replacement saying with
six months until justice breyer departs
the court the senate judiciary committee
will have ample time to hold hearings on
president biden's nominee
i really hope that they don't take all
of that time because that's exactly how
you get into a situation that allows
republicans to say now it's rushed now
it's right before an election we can't
do this don't do it democrats please
don't screw it up all right last week i
interviewed
vincent racinello
virologist from columbia university and
he said it does make some sense that
countries are starting to roll back
covet guidelines and restrictions
uh when you look at the uk
when you look at israel when you look at
other countries it makes some sense
because as this omicron wave goes down
it does seem like omicron is
significantly less deadly doesn't mean
everybody has only a cold but
there are some reports that say the
omicron death rate is 0.2 percent that
would put it at basically flu which is
0.15 percent
vaccines widely available
very good at preventing serious illness
and death
omicron tailored vaccine coming in a few
months
if not after this wave then when is sort
of the question that is increasingly
being asked of course bearing in mind
some people are going to need to be
careful for a long time because of
specific health situations denmark is
now
going back to normal
denmark will end most coveted
restrictions and quote welcome the life
we knew before denmark prime minister
metta frederickson announced
yesterday that denmark will throw out
most coveted pandemic restrictions that
it placed including masks restrictions
currently in place are for the public to
wear mask on public transit in
restaurants shops healthcare facilities
and retirement homes however
following the february 1 change of
restrictions which is tuesday masks will
only be required in hospitals healthcare
facilities and elderly homes we say
goodbye to the restrictions and welcome
the life we knew before frederickson
said as of february 1st denmark will be
open
according to health minister magnus
henneke
denmark's recent cases of covid were
more than 46 000 daily on average
however only 40 people are in hospital
intensive care units
we continue with a strong epidemic
surveillance then we can react quickly
if necessary despite lift of
restrictions fredriksen warned there
could be a rise in infections which may
lead to a fourth vaccination shot being
necessary which other countries have
found doesn't actually make sense
so
there are certainly controversies here
but this is a question many countries
are going to be faced with i don't
pretend to know the answer
one aspect of this that many uh doctors
are pointing to is
if not after this wave then when because
if this wave moves us to the endemic
phase where it takes on more of a
flu-like seasonal trajectory
with a lower death rate this
secondary omicron variant that now is
being looked at which may be even more
contagious but even milder although we
don't yet know for sure would push us
even closer to flu slash cold
what do you wait for is the question and
it's not for me about are we now at no
risk it's what milestone would we be
waiting for if indeed that's the
trajectory so i'm not pretending to know
what needs to happen
but i am asking
what would be the milestones if not in
another six weeks
as
the cases continue to decline rapidly if
they do in in many states massachusetts
for example cases are already down more
than 50 and declining very rapidly
nationally they're declining a little
less quickly
globally they're basically flat right
now globally we're now at the peak
rather than beyond it so
more and more countries going in this
direction doesn't seem the us is close
to it i think masks on planes in public
transit will be around for a while but
there may be changes coming i'm curious
to hear from you what direction you
think it needs to go you can find me on
twitter at dpakman and we'll be back
right after this short
break don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
hey so we're an independent media show
we're not part of some big conglomerate
we you know every piece of equipment
every healthcare dollar that goes
towards paying employee health insurance
you know all these things
they really come from you we're
primarily funded by the audience and i
would love it if you grabbed a
membership at joinedpakman.com to
support the work that we do and we want
to do more this weekend for example
we're going to have multiple
correspondents at the trump rally
talking to trumpists helping us to
understand what's going on we can only
afford to do those things and more
things going to debates and different
things as we get into the midterms we
can only do it with your support so
please sign up at joinpacman.com we've
got a bunch of great
member benefits including an extra show
that we do every day for our members and
you can use the coupon code wow 22
to discount the membership to an even
more
shockingly affordable rate at
joinpackman.com
all right i i did not plan to talk more
about sarah palin i know many of you
were hoping david never mentions sarah
palin again um a couple months ago one
month ago i guess six weeks ago sarah
palin said she would only get vaccinated
over her dead body she now has covered
and sarah palin's defamation suit
against the new york times was scheduled
to start this week and it's been delayed
because she has kovid we learned that
she has coveted sometime after saturday
saturday she was out at a restaurant in
manhattan we then learned she has
coveted
and yesterday she was out again sarah
palin is out at restaurants with kovid
and there's a bunch of different
elements to this freedom news reports
that sarah palin is seen dining at a
manhattan restaurant while waiting for
her trial to resume this was published
last night she was seen dining and
speaking with patrons at elio's italian
restaurant in the upper east side of
manhattan
following her positive cova test just
two days prior
she is seen with her group seated in the
outdoor area
um
she's just going out to eat i guess with
kovid let's take a look at a little bit
of this and i'll describe what's going
on in a moment
[Music]
so if you're only listening today and
not watching she's in one of these kind
of like indoor outdoor or outdoor indoor
things she's walking around
um
she's
you know knocking on the outdoor indoor
kind of tent type thing that that is
going on there
um and she uh she has coveted so there's
a couple of different interesting things
here one is
there are vaccine requirements in
manhattan for going to restaurants
indoors and from what we know on
saturday she was indoors so the first
question is
is she lying about being unvaccinated
she's actually unvaccinated
she's actually vaccinated claiming she's
unvaccinated but showed her vaccine
thing or
did this restaurant not actually check
it meaning they're violating the rules
in new york
we don't really we don't really know
the second part though and the bigger
part is
we're talking about saturday to
wednesday right so
she was out to eat saturday she tested
positive presumably sunday or later
she hasn't isolated for the required
five days she instead went out
to dinner
and
this is completely irresponsible in
every way just there's no there's no
math that says this makes sense she was
out saturday so presumably she wasn't
positive then
we learned she was positive sunday so
that gets a sunday monday tuesday
wednesday you're talking about 72 hours
later and she's already back out at a
restaurant so this we knew that we we've
known for a long time she's a disgusting
person
we've known for a long time that she's
probably a liar and whether she's lying
about the vaccination or we don't we
don't know but she's told all sorts of
other lies in the past
but she's just out with covid in new
york city and uh awaiting her defamation
trial now one other thing i do want to
mention and this is just kind of this
doesn't have anything to do with sarah
palin
i genuinely don't know at this point you
know that it's like
it's outdoor indoor they've placed an
indoor thing outdoors uh it's it's all
enclosed in plastic with heat and i
guess it's like slightly open i really
don't care like i go to this stuff as
well but to some degree i find it funny
when it's like
we've basically taken indoor dining and
put it outdoors sometimes there's a
completely and it's completely enclosed
um i i just don't know you know i don't
know what the risk level is and how it
varies in these different things i'm not
doing actual indoor dining right now as
i've said many times
but sometimes i look at the outdoor ones
and i'm like i'm basically indoors i'm
just
i'm i'm outside of the restaurant
but i'm clearly indoors in some kind of
enclosed thing
who knows who knows but that's what's
going on sarah palin out with covid out
on the town
we have
very
very bad news for republican congressman
matt gates
we have now
heard that matt gates was told
matt
you had sex with a minor she's under 18.
the broader context here
is this investigation that's now been
going on for we've known about it for
about 10 months into republican trumpian
congressman matt gates
who is being investigated for a whole
bunch of different things including
possibly having sex with a minor
sometimes we call that statutory rape
trafficking sex trafficking of a minor
across state lines
potentially paying people for sex
there's all these different things he's
denied everything and has lawyered up
with some of the best sex crimes defense
attorneys and one of the questions has
been
is he sort of like a bystander here and
he wasn't ever even really told hey some
of the stuff you're doing might not be
okay
there is an incredible blockbuster piece
of information now as the daily beast is
reporting witness can confirm matt gates
was told he had sex with a minor
one of the key interactions joel
greenberg this is like his wingman
claims to have had with matt gates is a
phone call informing gates they'd been
sleeping with a minor
someone witnessed the call meaning it is
not only greenberg that says this call
took place there's a witness that now
corroborates it here's the detail on
september 4 2017 according to his
confession letter joel greenberg called
his friend matt gates with some bad news
the teenager both men paid to have sex
with
was underage greenberg acclaimed
now two sources tell the daily beast
a cooperating witness can confirm
details of that call for one damning
reason
he was in greenberg's office when the
call took place
the witness big joe ellicott greenberg's
longtime best friend and an employee at
the seminole county tax office recently
pleaded guilty to fraud and drug charges
as part of a cooperation agreement
although ellicott has so far avoided
charges regarding sex trafficking of a
minor which greenberg pleaded guilty to
last may he was present for the call
that greenberg made to gates on
september 4th according to two people
the call they said was short and gates
was the one who ended it
um
this uh and and here is the specifics
immediately i called the congressman and
warned him to stay clear of this person
and informed him she was under age gates
was equally shocked and disturbed there
was no further contact with this
individual
until after her 18th birthday this is
just absolutely incredible now of course
investigators aren't stupid they are
going to look at phone records and i'm
sure already have to see if there is
such a call that took place between
greenberg and gates on september 4th of
2017 but we now have a witness to the
call greenberg and the witness both are
saying this call took place and this is
looking worse and worse for matt gates
now do we know if charges will be
brought no we don't know that
a lot of this comes to what can you
prove
um do we know
whether uh there were other such
instances where gates was repeatedly
told about the underage reality of this
woman we just don't have all of the
information but what do we know we are
10 months in and the investigation
hasn't ended
um
gates wing man is cooperating and has
pleaded guilty there is a cooperation
agreement for another individual
associated with the entire thing and
there are now specific assertions being
made that it wasn't just that it just so
happened that this is what took place
with gates gates was told that this is
what took place so
if i had to guess
this isn't going away anytime soon and
specifically if and when what particular
charges will be brought again against
gates we just don't know
we'll have a link to this article and
more information on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show you
can also follow me on instagram at
david.pacman
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show it's a great to welcome to the
program today brian karam who's an
award-winning journalist and author of
the new book free the press the death of
american journalism and how to revive it
great great having you i'm brian i
appreciate it thanks david a pleasure
being here so okay i mean when did the
death of american journalism start uh
where is was there a particular period
where we can start to see this demise
sure i blame uh richard nixon and roger
ailes both imps of the devil who uh
one came into office and you know
committed as many crimes as he could
and the other attached to him and
eventually spawned uh
mitch mcconnell and fox news
so uh those two together
began our journey and then it was um
ronald reagan who actually implemented
the first seeds that planted the first
seeds of destruction and every
every president in the last 40 years has
had their hand in doing it some more
than others some less and when we say
the death of journalism i mean in a
literal sense we have media outlets we
have people called reporters and all of
these things so like what what are you
talking about what is it that has had
that has degenerated
well the term for one uh you know to be
a reporter you have to at least have a
at least one copy editor otherwise
you're just some idiot spouting your
opinion and it's okay
i'm all fond of you know opinions but to
be a journalist you have to vet facts
and the process of how we do that is
broken down over the years how we do it
the institution is falling apart look
there's vast media the biggest problem
the the underlying largest problem in
the united states with journalism is a
lack of community journalism there are
vast informational deserts news deserts
in this country thousands of communities
where there is no local news and until
we fix that problem we can't fix the
bigger problem the smaller problem has
to be fixed with
investing in uh community newspapers
giving tax breaks to small business
owners you know what's wrong with a
hundred dollar rebate on your taxes if
you if you can prove you subscribe to a
newspaper or a radio station or
something that's that's where you start
because and look governments over the
last 40 years state local and federal
have gotten rid of
public notice ads and those are probably
one of the key things that you need to
build newspapers in fact those
those public notice ads provide
transparency on government everybody can
pick it up and go oh look here's an
estate sale the city council's meeting
friday and salesmen would use those and
lawyers would use them to find clients
and to find people to relate with in the
community and all of that helped build
our communities at the national level we
divide our communities by going you know
right or left but at the local level
everybody wants a paved street everybody
wants their you know the water to work
the lights to work you know the schools
to work hospitals police all of those
things that we have it that you know hey
why is that stoplight not working we
need to show up at a city council
meeting and find out but all of those
things have kind of broken down over the
years because of a lack of local and
community newspapers and until we fix
that and by the way that's where most
national stories start
is with community journalism they start
there
and until we invest in community
journalism we're not going to solve our
problems yeah so i mean there's so many
different areas that are factors here
and i'll just name some of them and then
maybe you could tell us whether these
are things that could be solved
individually or whether they're really
all part of the same thing so you've got
okay on the one hand you've got the
internet which has created essentially
this model
where at very little cost
you can
um essentially rewrite and do reporting
by phone rather than doing real
investigative journalism that has put
pressure on newspapers and other other
media outlets to say well let's
let's divest from the expensive
investigative journalists and instead do
this thing so that's one thing let me
mention a couple others all right well
let me address them one by one oh okay
so i don't forget it in that regard the
internet is a great thing
what newspapers and television and radio
and traditional media did wrong was to
get tied into the perpetual news cycle
and said we can vet facts and people
look people scream to the left and to
the right that were that were biased you
know conservatively we're biased
liberals no we're biased towards money
right because constriction of the
business we go where the money is yes so
you end up with news that you want
rather than news that you need
and that's the danger of if that was a
management problem and that's because we
have fewer experienced people in this
business anymore who can fend off the
the the need to go first oh they're
showing up live we have to do is take a
look at the steele dossier for example
all right the steele dossier came out
and the very first report said
not vetted this is not vetted
information and yet everyone ran with it
as if it were right that's the problem
so the internet isn't a problem it's a
solution with the right people behind it
no with without a doubt so so that's one
piece the technological factors that
have changed things second
um
we look at some other countries there's
a fee everybody pays towards public
broadcasting for example you talk about
what about a hundred dollar tax credit
if you subscribe to this or that
we also then have the entire debate
around hey you get a basic cable package
and some number of bucks is going to fox
news or whatever even if you don't want
it to and so people are paying
often
for so-called news that they don't even
actually want so there's that structural
issue that needs to be looked at as well
it seems to me well the problem there is
you need to reinstitute the fairness
doctrine so that you you know what has
happened um in a recent press conference
president biden referred to it as
informational alleys that we go into
alleys where we hear what we want to
hear and not what we need to hear
and i call it in the book informational
silos we're all kind of siloed into our
own existence and we never hear what
anybody else is saying sure well the
fairness doctrine helped increase uh
public um
news i mean it helps spawn the news
industry and so when you reinstitute a
fairness doctrine so you have to listen
to at least listen to the other side on
matters of import then perhaps you can
break down some of those informational
silos from what i've read though the the
the fairness doctrine as it previously
existed would essentially have no teeth
in an age where so much as i mean you
need something different you need
something different because of the
internet right well and that's one of
the things i say in the book is that you
need to have a blue ribbon commission to
look at it you need to institute the
fairness doctrine but you need people in
this industry and lawmakers to assess
how we can do it
you know so that it makes a difference
the real problem the fairness doctor
never really had
teeth i mean it never did no one was
ever lost a
you know a license because they didn't
adhere to the fairness doctrine it's
just that it kind of gave us all a
guardrail that we could all aim for and
so public service uh um programming
public affairs programming news all was
spawned by that i was it started in 1949
under the truman administration and
people said yeah okay you know they said
we're gonna sell you the airwaves but
for one hour a day or whatever you've
got to do public news and so that was
kind of without any you know real
consequence to it people fell in line
you need that today you need at least
the guardrail and then discuss how you
can make the guardrail solid but yeah it
doesn't it won't work you can't just
go all right reinstate the awareness
doctrine as it existed that won't work
but you need some form of fairness
doctrine to make sure that and make sure
that it does work what about the
socio-cultural shift that has taken
place in terms of attitudes towards news
and this includes two pieces one is
lack of media literacy where people
can't even tell whether they're watching
news or opinion so that's one side
people not really understanding what it
is that they're watching the other side
is this sort of contempt and we could
i'm curious to hear from you how
responsible trump was for this or others
about
if it's adversarial and you don't like
it it's fake or they're lying or they're
biased or or whatever to what degree
is that change and the attitude towards
what news is a problem here well taking
your last one first trump was a symptom
not a cause
trump is a con man who used existing
differences in division and further
exploited them
as he told you know i can't remember who
he told me he said look i i tell people
that you're the fake news so they don't
believe you right well you know don't
that's old that's really an old tactic
you know embodied in the statement don't
shoot the messenger you know we're just
giving it to you pal you don't like it
too bad go clean it up it's not upon us
to to say now we've lost i think to your
first part
what we've lost
over the years is there's a lack of
institutional knowledge and because of
that lack of institutional knowledge
caused by the constriction in our
business and that constriction in our
business was caused by the fact that
when i first got in this business there
were maybe two dozen companies that ran
80 of what you see reader here today
there's five
that commandeer about 90 of what you see
reader here right and that's because we
removed the restrictions on ownership
and so what happened was as larger and
larger companies began to buy each other
up and as they did bottom line counted
more there were fewer reporters like if
you owned a media conglomerate that used
to be comprised of four different or
five different or a hundred different
newspapers who all had reporters in
washington dc
for their specific newspaper you would
go well i can save money by just having
one reporter there right got rid of a
lot of jobs and experience and it became
more popular when i first got in this
business you had to have three to five
years of experience working as a beat
reporter somewhere in a small market so
you understood what it was to be a
reporter right and today they hire you
straight out of school and will hire you
and put you in the white house with no
experience at all
and therefore we lose our credibility
because what you end up with are
reporters without experience who are
more you know they're more susceptible
to the access journalism oh i won't be
able to get on air force one oh i won't
be allowed into this room oh i won't be
able to talk to these people if i do
this so that's led to what is a
disgustingly low level of real reporting
in the united states and it's only going
to get worse if we don't fix it you know
it was in 1958 that edward r murrow
appearing before the radio television
news directors association warned us
that if we don't clean up our act we are
destined to fall for nothing but slogans
and propaganda in the future and by god
we he nailed it
so what's the lowest hanging fruit
because you've got the media literacy
piece you've got the media consolidation
and lack of enforcement of antitrust
piece you've got regulatory fcc net
neutrality fairness doctrine aspect of
this you there's all these different
things what's the lowest hanging fruit
that would have the greatest impact most
quickly community newspapers invest in
them and give tax breaks for them and
encourage them
and uh that's where you start because
that's where you build reporters
some of the best reporters look why did
walter cronkite have so much gravitas in
1965 i think it was when he went to
vietnam and he he developed he put
together a documentary
which was all fact based and then at the
end of it he offered an opinion it's not
unusual for reporters to offer opinions
he offered one he said it's obvious to
this reporter that we're not going to
win we've got to negotiate our way out
of it and lbj said [ __ ] i've lost middle
america i've lost you know
cronkite i'm doomed i gotta you know i
won't run for reelection why did people
why did people respect that opinion
well because walter cronkite had the
gravitas to
to be able to say it he had covered
world war ii he was a radio beat
reporter he had experience upon
experience upon experience what anchor
today on any news show has that what
what what tell what
newspaper writer today has the gravitas
of an h l menkin
we don't have that because we have lost
institutional knowledge when you when it
costs too much to have a reporter around
they find other ways to make money
because guess what by the time you're in
your mid 30s or 40s and you got a family
you can't exist on what they're going to
pay you in this business as a reporter
so if i understand the community
newspaper a community media outlet piece
it's good because number one it creates
more diversity of opinion it's good
because number two it trains reporters
to be ready to go to the national level
number three it's good because
financially it's it's dividing money up
amongst more institutions like there's a
bunch of different ways in which that is
a positive thing right i agree and yeah
yeah i agree because i wrote it but
but
and then there are other things you know
like the reinstitution of the affair i
think you need a national shield law to
protect reporters so they don't go to
jail when they have confidential sources
as a reporter who was jailed four times
i can tell you it's not fun
um and then the most controversial thing
is and the thing that's that hurts and
bites the most for business is you know
using anti-trust legislation to bust up
the big monopolies right but it has to
be done in some respects somehow and
that's why you need a blue ribbon
commission to decide how to do it you
have to have more reporters on the
planet
there are twice the number of people on
this planet today is on the day that i
was born and probably about half the
number of reporters
that's a problem right and it's
illustrated best by a place i used to
work laredo texas
when i worked there in the 1980s there
were a hundred thousand people there
were three television stations that
broadcast in english one that broadcast
or two the broadcast
in um spanish there were two daily
newspapers in english and two in spanish
there were probably four or five radio
stations that broadcast news now that
was
35 years
almost 38 years ago and 100 000 people
today there are 300 000 people
and there's one television station
and one newspaper right right that's it
there's your problem in a nutshell
hey um
we had i'm gonna give you two examples
to kind of frame this next question and
you know you tell me what you think
under trump there was this famous
incident where
he flipped out on cnn's jim acosta and
then had his press credential pulled um
after jim acosta insisted on asking a
question and didn't immediately turn
turn the mic over when they tried to
take it from him last week joe biden or
maybe it was this week who knows uh
referred to fox reporter peter ducey as
a son of a [ __ ] and he he may have been
uh
knowingly on the mic or maybe not or
whatever
what those incidents are they equally
concerning in your mind
neither both one the other what do they
mean about the relationship between
federal government and the media
first of all jim acosta is a first
amendment warrior in 11.
and secondly
there were two people that had their
press passes pulled during the trump
administration
jim was the first i was the second and i
had to battle the sob i'll use the word
son of a [ __ ] i had to battle
trump that sob three times and i beat
him three times in court to keep my
press pass right
and jim fought him to keep his press
pass
that is what concerns me
i had to stand up in a in a court
a federal court
with my attorney ted butross who was
also a great first amendment warrior and
represented both me and jim
and and it was it was
ted who stood up and said you know
the administration said they had to ban
my press pass because if they didn't
come down on me and people like me that
they were afraid that reporters would
run through the halls mooning people
uh
honest to god
that was what they said
and imagine having to defend that
taking your time out as a reporter i had
to sit in court for that
me being called an sob by a president i
don't care
peter still gets in and i know peter and
i have nothing against any question that
anyone wants to ask in that briefing
room
there's no such thing as bad questions
only bad answers
god bless you for asking anything what
may not be the question i'd ask i may
think well that's kind of shallow but
it's it's always the answers that that
are more concerning for us you know
there's the old story told of uh during
betty ford's uh days when there was a
group of reporters including one fresh
off the choo choo who saw her in a
gaggle and the young reporters said hey
did your kids did your kids ever smoke
pot and everybody thought well that's
the stupidest question in the world
right up until the time where betty ford
said yes
right then he was brilliant right
you you may think a question is stupid
and reflect upon and go well that's a
stupid question but it's not the
questions that matter it's the answers
so i don't care if the the president
wants to call me a dumb sob or anybody
else in soap he gave him access and and
peter can still ask his questions so
there's a difference there a big
difference between having your press
pass
having to go to court to defend it
having a president fundamentally
unknowing or uncaring of what the first
amendment means and what a press is
there for and
then pro and a president who says hey
he's a dumb sob i mean i've heard
presidents say that pretty much about
every reporter in the white house so
that's not they're not equal they're not
equitable they're not there's no way
they're on the same level
and if you think differently i i invite
you to sit in court with me or jim if
you fight to keep our damn press passes
and keep doing our job yeah yeah the
distinct the exact distinction i made uh
after it happened the new book is free
the press the death of american
journalism and how to revive it the
book's author is brian karam brian
really appreciate your time today
sure anytime
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
all right i have a clip for you guys
today that i think you're going to
really enjoy now i have to tell you i
have not been able to get a straight
answer as to who the reporter is that
asked this bizarre cringy question
yesterday of jen saki during the press
briefing one person told me it was
someone from newsmax but the person from
newsmax has denied that they were even
there yesterday so i i don't know who
this is but i'm gonna play for you
such a cringy question this makes peter
ducey who regularly asks absurd
questions during the press briefings
actually seems sort of prepared and
there's a couple interesting things that
go on here
we're gonna hear a question read
that is literally being read you will
see the reporter looking down and
reading the question
and what happens sometimes is
when you read or use a talking point
that you don't really understand as soon
as there's any question asked about it
as soon as there's any even remote
pushback about it
it becomes humiliating and embarrassing
this happened when i was in los angeles
and was interviewed by jessie lee
peterson
jessie lee peterson was talking to me
about obama socialism because of phones
oh so-called obama phones and then he
got all confused about what even the
talking point is
and when you just get a talking point
you're supposed to use and you don't
even really understand it
it can end up being a complete and total
face plan and that's what happens here
now in this particular case the topic is
inflation and build back better and
whatever
if you're allergic to cringe i would
skip the next 90 seconds okay let's take
a look at this and a lot of you know 20
percent of this is gensake now having
some tools for handling these types of
bad faith questions eighty percent of it
is the reporter just not having any idea
what's going on check it out
okay go ahead just a quick question on
inflation
many people believe that government
spending is a big factor in the current
inflation levels by the way many people
believe is also good like that that
becomes a factor later as well can you
speak to concerns that spending plans
that come out of buildback better aren't
paid for and so could mean higher
deficits and more inflation in the
future aren't paid for
buildback better is paid for
entirely
okay so you've got to be able to say
where do you see that it's not paid for
because the whole thing with buildback
better was it is paid for now i'll talk
more about that in a moment you could
disagree with how it's paid for or you
could say i don't believe the number
right but you've got to be able to
because the whole thing with buildback
better was it is paid for
can you speak to the concerns that are
coming in that it's who are the concerns
from though
but who's saying it's not paid for
oh
this pause is maybe one of the most
significant pauses that i've ever seen
during a press briefing i'm even going
to back it up because every the pause is
everything here no
but who's saying it's not paid for
because there have been a range of
economists saying it's entirely paid for
now
i jen saki bails her out gen saki should
have allowed the silence to go on even
longer but she doesn't she bails her out
um and that has been a priority for the
president it has also been concluded by
a number of nobel laureates and experts
from uh a range of economic experts on
the outside that it will not contribute
to inflation so those are the global
experts that we would point to but there
may be others suggesting something else
but i don't know who those people are if
those bills do pass it will not raise
taxes now see this is now the here's the
problem
this is a completely different question
no you pay for it through taxation
that's so so the ques it's she the the
reporter doesn't seem to even understand
what's going on is it paid for verse
versus do any taxes go up or two
different questions and it's just a mess
this person has no business being in the
press briefing room
well it something being entirely paid
for means that part of that is the
highest income americans highest that
companies would be asked to pay paid for
means there's a cost but you raise the
money to pay for it a little bit more
that has been part of the proposal and
part of reforming the tax system to make
it more fair so they're also not
expected to contribute to future
inflation
then
like now she's just grasping its trust
the buildback better bill
again it's fully paid for we would point
to nobel laureates and a range of global
economists who have conveyed that it
would not contribute to inflationary
pressures go ahead i i almost am like
starting to feel bad because it's it's
so it's so so wacky you know the
question itself is just as bad as peter
ducey's questions but ducey is ready
with a comeback and he's ready with a
slicker goal post shift and that's where
she went wrong the silence is just
cringe-worthy and then she says so taxes
won't go up now
let's first talk about build back better
which seems to be basically dead
although joe biden is going to look at
whether he can do parts of it through
executive orders etc
there's a tax foundation general
equilibrium model which scored buildback
better
there's a congressional budget office
model which scored buildback better
the it's very close to revenue neutral
based on slightly different assumptions
now build back better has tax increases
on the rich
and some other different changes to
business taxes and other things which
would offset the spending so the concept
is very simple you do a hundred dollars
in spending but you take in an extra
hundred dollars that's 100 minus 100
right so you've got zero there that's
that's what paid for means in this
context
there is uh you know i have no interest
in obscuring from you guys that
there is disagreement as to whether
things would cost exactly what is
projected 10 years out
and as to whether
the exact amount of revenue would be
raised that the biden administration
predicts there's a real question when
you're talking about spending projected
out years and revenue projected out
years particularly when the revenue is
not if i recall correctly
accounting for a dynamic tax model which
says well okay
here's how much you would get if you
change the tax and nobody changes their
behavior
but typically when you change a tax
people do change their behavior you've
got to account for that i'm more than
glad to admit that to you guys because
that's the case with any bill
uh you could say hey you know what
this actually could be a little bit uh
this could actually raise the deficit a
little bit because this thing's gonna
cost a little bit more and this thing is
gonna raise a little bit less money
that's perfectly fair and and that would
be the case with any one of these bills
the problem is the reporter doesn't even
know what's going on she seems dazed she
doesn't seem to understand even the
difference between
paying for something
and what it means to raise taxes or what
is what does revenue neutral mean she
just has absolutely no business being
there and jen saki handling it well but
it's not a difficult one to handle
because she's completely clueless i want
to just stick in one little story here
about the grift train that continues to
happen with the former president donald
trump we did 15 minutes at the top of
the show
about the upcoming retirement of supreme
court justice stephen breyer stephen
breyer 83 years old is going to be
retiring and joe biden will get his
first of we don't know how many supreme
court picks
from his uh presidency and um it is
going to be yeah i'm sure just a pretty
pretty mainline liberal who will keep
the balance on the court at six to three
and donald trump has immediately started
scam grifting off of this donald trump
putting out a statement within minutes
within minutes of the news breaking that
stephen breyer will be retiring through
his save america pack and it reads
breaking supreme court justice breyer
announces retirement
that's true
okay that may be the only thing here
that's true trump going on to say joe
biden will fill the vacant seat with a
liberal activist
president trump has activated an
emergency 5x impact
to defend his america first legacy now
aside from whether biden will pick some
extreme liberal which he won't
um
the idea that this does anything to
trump's legacy you're replacing a
liberal with liberal
trump still got his three wacky right
wingers including one who replaced ruth
bader ginsburg so the idea that this
even does any whatever you think about
trump's legacy this really does nothing
to change it um and then it says please
contribute any amount immediately to
claim your 5x impact and to save
president trump's legacy um it doesn't
actually even say who is multiplying
this so the idea here it shows if you
make a 45 contribution another 225. 5x
another 225 will be matched so by
donating 45 your impact is 270 dollars
it's all probably a lie i mean you know
it's conceivable that this one time it's
not a scam
but it's probably a lie and there's no
indication here about who is matching
these funds or what what is going on but
immediately trump jumping on the scam
wagon and my prediction is this uh this
saturday trump's doing another rally
this one is in conroe texas we're gonna
have people on the ground there
interviewing trumpists we'll try to talk
to them a little bit about the supreme
court and see what they have to say
but my guess is
trump will
use this supreme court situation during
his speech once again to try to justify
the election of trumpists in november i
mean it'll be completely wacky it'll
make no sense but my guess is he will
try to do that um and we will we will
wait and see but trump immediately
jumping on the grift wagon uh trying to
fundraise off of the retirement of
stephen of uh justice stephen breyer
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is one of my favorite voicemail
types
and it is when someone tells me
i should really go to communist
countries if i love them so much
ignoring the fact that i have no
interest in communism or communist
countries take a listen
yeah i just heard your comments on the
trump rally right i think you really
need to try um
try something like a special exercise
you know like a knee squat reach far
back because you can't with both hands
try to hold on to your ears or cat find
your ears and hold on to them and pull
your head out of your rear end i'm
having trouble picturing this but let's
continue
you're obviously one of those liberals
that's
got gay tendencies and gay tendencies
it's like what what is what does that
even have to do with anything
it's always anti-semitic or homophobic
at its core
very un-american go to a communist
country and live there and see how you
like it there this is so funny because
as many of you know
much of my audience hates that i'm not a
communist but i'm not a communist i'm
not interested in communist countries
stalinist leninism is not something i'm
a fan of uh chavez maduro i'm not a fan
you know what however you want to desi
uh define
the ideal socialist or communist kind of
wha whatever that's not me
find someone else i i'm not interested
in that i'm interested in
uh capitalist northern european
democracies i'm interested yeah come on
guys give me a break but as usual
somewhere in there is some homophobia in
this case sometimes it's anti-semitism
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about the neil young
joe rogan spotify debacle we will talk
about the
heart transplant denial due to no covet
vaccine that many of you have written to
me about and much more all of those
stories on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access
you